et du jour cet anti amis confiné du jour
bonjour
j'espère qu'on entend correctement ce la
voix bienvenue dans ce facebook live qui
est centré sur l'action individuelle
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'utile pour
faire baisser les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et jouer sa part on va
dire dans l'action collective ou dans
l'action que nous devons mettre en
oeuvre
si on veut éviter de finir comme des
poulets rôtis donc justement si on veut
éviter que le climat de derry faut alors
je il ya un certain nombre de questions
qui ont été posées là comme d'habitude
sur la page avec un système de
classement alors je vais respecter la
démocratie dans un premier temps et
prendre celle est qui on est et on va
dire plébiscité comme j'imagine qu'elle
intéresse un certain nombre de gens il
ya une première question qui a été posée
sur alors que j'oublie existe-t-il une
étude sérieuse et crédible qui met en
perspective les actions individuelles du
quotidien versus les décisions
politiques concernant l'action
climatique alors la réponse est oui
il se trouve qu'il ya une action par ou
via une étude qui a été faite alors je
sais pas si elle est sérieuse
il dirait en la lisant mais en tout cas
il ya une tentative qui a été fait par
carbone 4 qui s'appelle faire sa part
donc l'étude est disponible sur le site
de carbone 4 si vous tapez car votre
carte refaire sa part vous arriver
dessus et on a précisément les auteurs
de cette étude ont précisément essayer
de quantifier
combien est ce que on pouvait réduire
son empreinte carbone par des actions
individuelles et qu'est ce qui reste est
quelque part à la charge de la
collectivité
j'ai donné quelques exemples l'empreinte
carbone des établissements
d'enseignement ou un certain nombre
d'entre vous entraîner leurs guêtres
quand il était petit
voir en ce moment et où pour un certain
d'entre vous vos enfants traînent leurs
guêtres en ce moment parce qu'ils ont le
droit d'y être tournée et bien
manifestement ce n'est pas une action
individuelle qui fait que ces
établissements sont
- chauffer plus isolé ou évite d'acheter
des tablettes
au lieu d'acheter des crayons à papier
ce qui en plus est meilleur pour la
mémorisation des élèves soit dit en
passant
donc là on est typiquement dans un cas
de figure dans lequel ça ne relève pas
de l'action individuelle de même que
cela ne relève pas de l'action
individuelle que l'armée française
utilise des avions qui consomment plus
ou moins qui rosen ou que l'on mette des
infrastructures de transport comme ceux
ci et comme cela donc le principe de
cette étude a été de regarder
j'ai envie de dire à périmètre constant
à états du pays donné ce qu'on pouvait
faire d'utile pour faire baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
en gros ce que ce que conclut ce travail
c'est qu'il ya une moitié de l'empreinte
carbone qui relèvent assez directement
de choix que l'on peut faire quand bien
même la collectivité décide de ne pas
bouger alors dans ses choix
il ya sans grande surprise ce qui
concerne le régime alimentaire il est
évident que quand on baisse la fraction
de viande rouge qu'on mange et d'autres
produits laitiers qui m'ont avec serbe
est l'empreinte carbone il ya un volet
qui concerne le logement il ya un volet
qui concerne les achats et il ya un
volet qui concerne les déplacements
et puis ces actes ont été segmenté en
deux sous ensemble il ya ce que vous
pouvez faire sans investissement
typiquement par exemple manger moins de
viande c'est quelque chose qui ne
demandent pas d'investissement ça
demande de la volonté de s'y coller mais
ça ne demande pas d'argent
est ce que vous pouvez faire avec
investissement alors avec investi par
avec investissement c'est typiquement
vous êtes dans un logement qui est
chauffée aux combustibles fossiles sur
le gaz et vous décidez de passer à la
pompe à chaleur
voilà ça c'est ça demande un
investissement mais ça relève encore de
l'action individuelle au sens où la
collectivité n'a pas besoin de se
comporter différemment pour que vous
puissiez faire ce geste qui va permettre
la baisse des émissions
l'autre moitié alors tout ça évidemment
un tout petit côté arbitraire parce que
dans il ya une partie des émissions qui
concerne les achats le degré de gains
qu'il faut avoir sur les émissions liées
à la production de vos lunettes de vos
chemises ou de vos chaises
c'est aussi fonction de la quantité de
lunel de chemise et de chaises que vous
avez envie d'utiliser bien évidemment
l'efficacité technique
elle ne fait que refléter la partie
qu'on ne souhaite pas prendre sur la
sobriété
si on n'achète plus rien il n'y a pas
besoin de faire des efforts sur les
émissions industrielles puisque toute
façon on n'achète plus rien donc
l'empreinte carbone de ses achats est
devenu donc là la question de savoir
comment est ce qu'on fait la part des
choses entre l'action individuelle et
d'actions collectives dépens un petit
peu quand même
de là on met la barre de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le nécessaire ou ce
qu'on pourrait appeler les besoins
sachant que dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les besoins dans le monde
économique
en fait on peut souvent segment des ca
en dessous ensemble qui sont les vrais
besoins
typiquement manger dormir boire
communiqué clés semblables pour
considérer que ça fait partie des
besoins aussi et puis ce qui relève
simplement des désirs solvables avoir
une voiture plus grosse plutôt qu'une
plus petite ou avoir une voiture plutôt
qu'un vélo
souvent ça relève du désir solvables
c'est pas vraiment un besoin au sens de
si on l'a pas on n'en meurt pas eh bien
il ya bien sûr une ligne de partage des
eaux un peu un peu flou encore une fois
entre ce qui relève de la collectivité
ce qui relève de l'action individuelle
mais en gros on peut dire qu'on est face
à deux morceaux qui sont de taille il va
à peu près équivalente
donc pour diviser par quatre le par-5
l'empreinte carbone d'un français en
gros les individus dont confère la
moitié du chemin et la collectivité
devant faire l'autre moitié c'est ça
qu'on a dit dans ce travail a alors
est-ce que c'est suffisamment sérieux
[Musique]
j'avais pas on verra est ce que c'est
une tentative sérieuse ça on peut
considérer quand même que oui alors
après il ya un complément à cette
question qui est comment est ce qu'on
arrive à faire la part des choses si je
lui comprend à peu près la façon dont ça
a été posée entre les choses qui sont
vraiment des décisions collectives
majeurs et des décisions anecdotique
individuel anecdotique alors il est
évident que le recyclage des tasses à
café un que moi je voulais tasse à café
pour la page de table en fait c'est
qu'ils étaient des gestes sur lesquels
il ya des sociétés qui ont beaucoup
communiqué quand on était au début
préhistoire de la lutte contre le
changement climatique c'est-à-dire il ya
une vingtaine d'années aujourd'hui ça
peut paraître comme étant des gestes
essais des gestes totalement anecdotique
qui n'avait pour seule justification que
de préparer le moment où on en ferait
des plus significatifs j'ai toujours été
très perplexe face à cette explication
pas perplexe au sens où je dis c'est pas
vrai mais perplexe au sens où je n'ai
jamais réussi à bien savoir si au fond
les petits gestes prépare les gros ou si
les petits gestes serve d'excusé
absolutoire pour ne pas faire les gros
vous vous rappellerez peut-être de ce
sketch qui avaient eu lieu avec les
personnages de groland
enfin dans le cadre de groland plus
exactement il n'y avait pas cinq ou dix
ans le canal plus qui avait diffusé ça
où on voyait monsieur crado et monsieur
écolo alors toute la semaine monsieur
crado faisait des tas de trucs vachement
bien il avait une voiture électrique
et puis à la fin de la semaine il ya
quand même là j'ai bien méritée donc je
vais aller jouer au golf au maroc eh
bien c'était il ya un petit côté qu'il y
a ça dans les petits gestes
c'est à dire que on ne sait pas si au
fond encore une fois ils sont faits par
des gens qui par ailleurs font aussi des
gros geste et ce à leur fin fond des
grosses pollution va dire et ça sert aux
gestes absolutoire ou bien si ça prépare
les beaux gestes il ya une étude de
l'ademe qui avait fait il ya une dizaine
d'années un travail qui était très
intéressant donc je me demande même si
je l'avais pas traduit sur un site perso
dans une de ces innombrables pages dont
je ne me souviens plus où il avait posé
à gens qu'ils avaient interrogé un
certain nombre de questions pour sur des
petits gestes
est-ce que vous triez vos ordures est ce
que vous êtes et la lumière quand vous
sortez d'une pièce etc
et puis les coquins leur avait demandé
également comment est ce que vous allez
au travail
est-ce que vous avez une grande ou une
petit un petit logement etc et en fait
il s'avérait que les gens qui faisaient
le plus de petits gestes étaient aussi
ceux qui avaient la plus grosse
empreinte carbone il ya un vrai débat
sur la question
2 est ce que les petits l'est près par
les gros encore une fois où est-ce que
ça sert à donner bonne conscience quand
on a un gros impact sur la planète par
exemple comprendre où l'avion et qu'on
n'a pas du tout l'intention de changer
sur ce terrain là voilà donc quelques
questions la question posée sur est ce
que ça vaut le coup de donner de la
lumière à des actions allaient
anecdotique ou anodine je suis pas sûr
en tout cas ce dont je suis absolument
persuadé c'est que quand on le fait il
serait honnête de rappeler que c'est des
toutes petites actions et que à tout le
moins ça sert au mieux d'apéritif et
sûrement pas de plat de résistance entre
est encore une fois les gens qui
diffusent cette information parfois sont
eux mêmes dans la même schizophrénie
c'est à dire que ils ont la même
difficulté à ne pas faire les gestes
qu'ils ont vraiment de l'importance
alors après une autre question qui est
celle de la de là
sensibilisation des proches au problème
voilà une des actions individuelles
ayant le plus d'impact environnemental
et de sensibiliser ses proches au
problème et c'est très dur de le faire
alors d'allonger une objection en ce
moment une des actions qui a le plus
d'impact environnemental et diffuser un
nouveau virus
alors je peux dire que nous parlons
c'est une mauvaise blague donc
sensibiliser ses proches au problème
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
est difficile
pourquoi parce que tous autant que nous
sommes et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle les vieux comme moi en plus de
mal à abandonner dans ses habitudes que
les jeunes qui ne sont pas encore prises
c'est que un truc dont on a horreur tous
autant qu on s est d'abord donné nous
rentrent abandonné ses rentes c'est un
des trucs les gens ont le plus de mal à
faire c'est aussi pour ça que vous
n'arrivez pas à convaincre les
climato-sceptiques un climato sceptiques
en général est quelqu'un qui ne supporte
pas d'abandonner sa rente que ce soit
une rente économique une rente de
réputation une rampe de croyance une
fois voilà c'est une situation installé
qu'on n'a pas envie d'abandonner et bien
au fond tous pareils et donc quand on
nous dit ah c'était vachement bien
l'avion mais maintenant tu vas devoir
faire sans ses dégagements vient d'être
chauffé mais maintenant tu vas devoir
faire sans et c'était vachement bien
d'acheter tout ce qui passait par la
tête au sol de maintenant tu vas devoir
faire sans
c'est évident que ça vient heurter des
habitudes et on n'aime pas trop ça on a
on a du mal le gpat parts égales face à
ça il ya il n'y a pas de ya pas de
solution miracle
il ya quelques éléments de réponse que
je peux vous donner un des premiers une
des premières raisons que les gens
peuvent avoir de ne pas vouloir changer
leurs habitudes c'est qu'en général on a
constitué un cercle de relations qui
étaient en phase avec les habitudes
qu'on avait par exemple si vous avez
beaucoup les voyages il ya des chances
que vous fréquentiez d'autres personnes
qui aiment beaucoup les voyages et donc
quand vous réunissez vous parlez de
voyages etc
si vous décidez de ne plus prendre
l'avion et de ne plus faire ses voyages
à ce moment non seulement vous renoncer
à l'avion mais vous renoncez également
au cercle social qui allait avec la
discussion qui va avec l'avion c'est à
dire
seuls des voyages c'est exactement
pareil en ce qui concerne les achats si
vous aviez l'habitude d'acheter le moins
de gadgets électroniques qui vous passer
sous le nez à nouveau la probabilité
n'est pas complètement nul que vous ayez
fréquenté du coup des gens avec qui vous
partagiez l'envi d'expliquer que vous
aviez un nouveau machin qui fait ceci
cela que c'est la shdm en bien et que le
nouveau modèle d'ordinateur ou le
nouveau modèle de smartphone il arrive à
prendre des photos comme ceci est un
essai et donc si vous n'êtes plus dans
cette démarche là au niveau consommation
vous vous privez aussi du de
l'interaction sociale qui va avec et
donc plus largement il me semble que les
gens qui décident de changer de mode de
vie
ils doivent aussi une des difficultés
évidentes accepter que la nature des
relations qu'ils entretiennent avec les
autres changent aussi parce que c'est
compliqué de continuer à fréquenter des
gens qui font les dix linverse de ce que
vous considérez après coup comme étant
devenu le bon exemple à suivre où les
bonnes choses à dire donc le l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles c'est compliqué
de changer ses habitudes c'est parce que
en fait on abandonne quelque part une
communauté et on en n'a pas encore
trouvé une autre et s'intégrer dans une
communauté est quelque chose qui est
important pour l'espèce humaine
du reste en ce moment les d'une façon
tragique on le voit dans d'autres dans
d'autres cas de figure donc le on a on a
tous besoin d'un peu de communautarisme
d'être dans une communauté dans un
endroit où on partage des choses donc là
une des solutions au changement c'est
d'arriver à créer chez les gens qu'on
essaye de faire changer l'envi de
rejoindre une communauté où ils vont y
trouver un avantage alors je sais pas
moi ça peut être
et à ce moment pardon et à ce moment la
question de la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre deviendra juste le
co produit ou le support aux
sous-produits d'une démarche qui aura un
autre avantage par ailleurs notamment le
fait
de permettre des interactions sociales
on n'avait pas avant donc c'est voilà
c'est un petit premier réflexion que je
peux donner sud est du reste le fait de
voir de la sobriété comme étant quelque
chose à la mode participent typiquement
de ce comportement parce que être à la
mode c'est s'identifier avec communauté
c'est s'identifier à un collectif et
c'est pour ça que ça peut marcher chez
certaines personnes parce que
précisément ça leur permet de s'intégrer
dans une dans une communauté
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus facile
pour les jeunes parce que les jeunes ils
ont pas encore de rente a abandonné ils
sont à un stade où ils ont encore une
vie à construire
ils ont encore alors c'est pas que c'est
pas vrai complètement chez les ados
s'ils ont été totalement gaver de marque
mais il ya quand même une géant vidéo
une marge de manoeuvre qui existe de
manière plus forte
on peut aussi quand on est jeune et
c'est une autre question qui a été posée
j'y reviendrai après m'être son activité
professionnelle en accord avec ses
valeurs personnelles
c'est plus dur une fois qu'on a une
activité professionnelle qui est
frontalement antagoniste avec la baisse
des émissions et on s'en rend compte
d'adhérer un discours de cette nature
donc si vous êtes pilote de ligne ou
que vous opérez dans une centrale à
charbon c'est plus difficile que si vous
êtes réparateur de vélos de basculer
entre guillemets du bon côté de la
france donc voilà c'est quand quand on
se demande pourquoi est ce que les gens
ne veulent pas entre guillemets il faut
bien penser à ça il faut bien penser au
fait que nous avons besoin de confort
affectif et morale et qu' il faut
regarder dans quelle mesure ce confort
affectif et morale et cette capacité à
s'intégrer dans une communauté
combien cette attaque et et combien on
peut le restaurer
quand on se met à changer de à changer
de comportement
c'est toujours beaucoup plus facile
quand les gens font ça à plusieurs c'est
absolument évident alors après il ya une
question sur le parachute du conte fonce
dans le mur en klaxonnant comment se
préparer individuellement au choc qui
nous attend alors là je vais vous faire
un petit coup de pub au service il faut
s'y préparer collectivement
en fait ça renvoie à la question
précédente se préparer individuellement
personnellement j'y crois pas trop
je ne suis pas totalement convaincu par
le comportement survivalistes du cow boy
américain où on va s'enterrer au fin
fond du désert avec des boîtes de
conserve pour 50 ans des graines de tout
ce qui pousse un fusil cinquante mille
cartouches
il croit qu'à moitié je crois plutôt que
la bonne façon d'être dire d'être
résilient c'est d'avoir le plus possible
une valeur pour les autres parce qu'à ce
moment là les autres vous veulent du
bien
les autres participent à vous préserver
si vous êtes seul contre tous
faut quand même être vraiment très très
très fort pour arriver à survivre dans
des conditions sympathique c'est quand
même beaucoup plus facile quand on
s'intègre dans un collectif donc en fait
ça renvoie à la question précédente
quelque part il vaut mieux se préparer
collectivement que se préparer
individuellement et se préparer
individuellement la première des choses
à faire me semble-t-il est justement de
commencer à intégrer une collectivité où
on va pouvoir faire des choses ensemble
alors faire des choses ensemble
ça veut dire en particulier se mettre
dans un réseau
dans lequel il ya un chacun peut amener
quelque chose à un groupe plus large qui
lui sera nécessairement mieux préparée
face à ce qui nous attend
alors il ya des gens qui s'organisent en
village par exemple avec des logements
qui sont faiblement consommateurs une
zone agricole pas loin opérée par eux ou
pas opéré par eux qui leur permet de se
nourrir etc
ça c'est déjà quelque chose qui pour moi
fait beaucoup plus ans qu'une action est
purement individuelle maintenant il est
probable que il restera aussi des gens
en ville pendant au moins un certain
temps las alors il faut toujours
réfléchir de manière contextualiser dans
ce genre de dans ce genre de situation
donc ya pas une martingale qui
s'applique à tous
ce qui est sûr c'est que plus on est
mentalement en fait une bonne partie de
la préparation quand on est en ville et
mentale c'est à dire être moins surpris
que les autres par les choses qui vont
parler paris surprise pardon pour la
répétition qu'on va avoir essayé d'avoir
[Musique]
essayé d'envisager un avenir qui ne soit
pas unique
souvent c'est en réfléchissant à la
façon dont l'avenir peut se présenter et
en comprenant que l'éventail des
possibles est ouvert que l'on se
préparer efficacement à ce moment là on
se dit ah bah tiens ici il se passe ça
qu'est ce que je ferais ce qui se passe
ça qu'est-ce que je suis avec elle ce
qui se passe ça qu'est ce que je vais
prendre un exemple totalement idiot lors
des 2 dernières canicule qui a eu à
paris il ya des gens qui ne pouvaient
pas rester dans l'appartement qui était
sous les combles parce qu' il pouvait
pas dormir dedans on veut vous voyez on
peut considérer que ça fait partie de la
préparation à ce qui va arriver soit de
déménager souad isoler son logement
contre le show du reste il ya une
question qui a été posée quand on
s'assoit de demander aux propriétaires
de le faire donc ça ça peut faire partie
de la préparation on n'est pas
nécessairement dans la survie
individuelle face à un monde hostile et
des hordes de barbares qui déferle
voilà donc le
la préparation elle va à la fois avec le
fait de bien essayer de comprendre ce
qui pourrait se passer
envisager des futurs qui sont très
discriminés et finalement faire pour soi
comme on peut faire quand on fait un
travail dans une entreprise puis et
surtout essayer de se mettre en réseau
en général c'est ça le canton quad les
situations difficiles les gens qui s'en
sortent bien sont toujours des gens qui
étaient dans une situation dans lesquels
ils étaient intégrés dans un réseau donc
là la première des choses à faire est
probablement celle là a alors après une
question beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
alors je prends une question à la volée
mes camarades bouddhisme ne sont pas
concernés par le changement climatique
lorsque le sujet arrive sur leurs tables
bas la seule chose qu'on peut essayer de
faire en pareil cas c'est de leur dire
bah écoute va regarder d'un peu près en
quoi ça consiste et d'immenses ensuite
c'était pesant pas concernés alors si
vous êtes un peu de chacun pour lui
redire même bakchich de fermer même pas
cap d'affaires saas et c'est comme dans
le field à 4 pas cap t'es même pas cap
de passer dix ans regarder pour me dire
ensuite ce que tu auras compris la voie
là mais je redis c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas toujours très simple si vous
essayez de le prendre sous forme de jeu
des fois ça ça marche un peu mieux donc
une question sur qu'est ce qui pèse le
plus lourd dans notre empreinte carbone
alors en gros notre empreinte carbone
c'est comme un bon gâteau
sauf que c'est un mauvais cadeau c'est
un 4/4 en gros un quart des émissions
c'est l'alimentation
un quart des émissions c'est les achats
un quart des émissions c'est les
déplacements et un quart des émissions
c'est pour une bonne part le logement et
pour une petite part les services
publics alors je reprends dans l'ordre 1
car c'est l'alimentation alors c'est pas
exactement des cas rares mais c'est
l'alimentation alors pourquoi s'il ya
des gaz à effet de serre dans
l'alimentation
parce que les chants sont cultivés
aujourd'hui avec des engrais azotés
fabriquer ces en grèce a conduit à
émettre du co2
c'est les engrais azotés sont fabriqués
avec du gaz on commence par craquer les
molécules de méthane avec de l'eau pour
faire de l'hydrogène cet hydrogène on
l'associé à de l'azoté de l'air pour
faire du maniaque et c'est un maniaque
sert de constituants de base pour faire
les anglaises un petit morceau c'est le
diesel détracteurs et enfin quand on
épand les anglais un petit bourg soit
aussi celle et phytosanitaires alors
quito sanitaire c'est très toxique mais
ça fait pas beaucoup d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre parce que on en utilise
pas des grandes quantités par rapport
aux angles et enfin les anglais impôts
vous donner un ordre de grandeur les
phytosanitaires et c'est évidemment
beaucoup trop
on en est pas en france chaque année
entre 50 et 100 mille tonnes les engrais
on en utilise plutôt dix fois plus c'est
plusieurs millions de tonnes quand ces
engrais azotés on les et pan sur le sol
ça engendre des émissions de protoxyde d
azote qui est un gaz à effet de serre et
qui bien évidemment rentrer du coup dans
le bilan carbone des cultures après une
bonne partie de ce qu'on mange ça va
consister en des animaux qui ont ruminé
donc les boeufs les volets vaches et non
pas les cochons comme d'un père était de
total ait qui ne reviennent pas donc les
volets vaches et les boeufs les moutons
les chèvres et les mouflons quand on en
attrape m'a dit je ne sais plus qui et
bien tout ça rumine et donc la
rumination ça émet du méthane parce que
la rumination consiste à avoir de la
fermentation de constituants végétaux
dans les estomacs des ruminants parce
que les ruminants quatre estomacs et
c'est arrivé du méthane qui compte
également pour une partie très
significative de l'empreinte carbone de
l'alimentation enfin il faut rajouter à
ça la fabrication des emballages les
transports intermédiaire l'énergie des
industries agroalimentaires d'énergie de
réfrigération dans les grandes surfaces
avant bref si vous mettez tout ça
boutabout vous avez un bon quart de
notre empreinte carbone qui vient de ce
qu'on mange
et là dedans je n'ai pas compté la
déforestation qui a lieu dans le monde
et qui pour l'essentiel il y est
également à la nécessité d'obtenir de
nouvelles surfaces alimentaires pour une
population de nouvelles surfaces
agricoles pendant pour une population
qui d'une part est en croissance et
d'autre part augmente la
quitter de viande qu'elle mange par
personne parce que c'est ça actuellement
la tendance mondiale
si je rajoute la déforestation au niveau
mondial on est au delà du car on est on
est au delà du tiers même après le
deuxième quart pour les français c'est
ce qu'on achète alors ce qu'on achète
c'est tout les chemises des tables comme
je le disais tout à l'heure les canapés
l'informatique l'été le papier q les
shampoings voilà absolument tout ce que
vous achetez les rasoirs à tout ce qui
ne se mange pas alors ces achats à
nouveaux emprunts de carbone vient du
fait que les industries à pardon je
reviens à faire sa part dans
l'alimentation vous avez donc une marge
de manoeuvre importante qui est de
manger moins de viande et en particulier
- de moins de viande rouge
il ya un petit bémol à ça c'est que si
on le fait sans contrepartie pour les
éleveurs les éleveurs meurt donc si vous
mangez plus de viande rouge depuis des
heures
il se trouve que les éleveurs
aujourd'hui c'est les paysans qui ont la
situation la plus économique la plus
difficile ou parmida plus une situation
difficile
parmi eux l'agriculteur qui suivit le
plus et donc il serait souhaitable que
la collectivité accompagne ce mouvement
en augmentant le prix payé aux éleveurs
contre des chartes de qualité contre des
labels donc pour moi le bon système est
pas un système dans lequel tout le monde
devient végétarien c'est un système dans
lequel on divise la quantité de viande
rouge par deux à trois mais dans ce
contexte là on fournit aux éleveurs les
moyens de vivre correctement en
augmentant le prix au kilo qu'on leur
paye par 4 à 6 de telle sorte qu'ils
aient les moyens de faire quelque chose
qui soit très correct sur le plan
environnemental et l'essentiel du
cheptel bovin qui disparaîtraient en
pareil cas c'est le cheptel bovin que
vous ne voyez pas quand vous êtes dans
la campagne puisque c'est celui qui est
dans les grands halls à l'ensilage dans
des stabulations pardon fin de la
parenthèse
donc maintenant deuxième quart des
achats alors les achats là c'est clair
que c'est compliqué d'arbitrer ces
achats
de façon très simple il faut avoir des
informations un peu fine pour savoir
comment on peut procéder est du reste
est une autre question qui avait été
posé qui est ce qu on pourrait avoir un
oeil ou cas du carbone exactement qu'on
aille et yoka de l'alimentation et
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas avoir sur
chaque produit le contenu carbone de sa
fabrication
non j'y reviendrai après la réponse est
en théorie oui en pratique ça va pas
être simple mais met donc vous avez un
certain nombre de d'actions qui sont
possibles sur les achats la première
c'est de renoncer à un achat la deuxième
c'est ici vous vraiment vous n'avez pas
envie de renoncer vous pouvez quand même
essayer de discriminer alors il ya des
il ya des domaines dans lesquels c'est
pas compliqué par exemple sur tout ce
qui est électronique de loisirs télé
ordinateur et ses premières règles en
acheter le moins souvent possible et 2e
rei quand vous les achetez achetez les
les plus petits entre guillemets les
plus petit possible donc acheter les
smartphones avec le moins de mémoire
possible les télés avec la plus petite
diagonale d'écran possible parce que en
gros les émissions de fabrication sont
proportionnelles à la taille de l'objet
et à ses performances et un ordinateur
c'est pareil essayez de lâcheté potro et
2 et donc pas avec une trop grande
diagonale d'écran et pas avec trop bien
loin puisque c'est ça qui c'est ça qui
en gros conduit à des émissions
importantes sur les autres achats
d'appareils essayer de reprise et les
vêtements plutôt que de les racheter ou
acheter de l'occasion plutôt que
d'acheter du neuf il ya toutes ses
marges de manoeuvre sont liées au fait
que quand on achète et bien on fait
vivre mais c'est aussi le sujet
l'industrie qui est à l'avant et qui a
engendré les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre avec la métallurgie la chimie
primaire puis les assemblages derrière
les transports intermédiaires etc
donc c'est un quart après un troisième
quart c'est les déplacements alors dans
les déplacements vous avez en gros
1 20% pour les déplacements individuels
sont liés à l'avion 20 % de l'empreinte
carbone des déplacements c'est là bien
et 80 % de l'empreinte carbone c'est la
voiture alors l'avion est cependant très
mal répartis par couches sociales vous
avez alors l'étude a été faite en grande
bretagne en france je sais pas ce que ça
donne mais en grande bretagne 50% des
vols en avion sont faits de mémoire par
10% de la population
donc en fait il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ne prennent quasiment jamais l'avion et
il ya une petite fraction de la
population qui prend très souvent
l'avion en ces gens là sont difficiles à
convaincre
ça c'est très clair si vous en
connaissez dans votre entourage leur
expliquer pourquoi dans les yeux qu'est
ce qu'ils font c'est pas bien que ça tue
les coraux que ça fait graver les forêts
et que ça va provoquer des migrations
bon courage faire parler jamais eu
beaucoup de succès quand j'ai essayé de
me lancer dans ce genre de croisade
nommé mais clairement sur les
déplacements donc qu'elles sont
importants la voiture 20% l'avion sur la
voiture toujours pourquoi vous assommer
deux chiffres en gros deux tiers c'est
de la mobilité du quotidien donc c'est
des déplacements raisonnablement court
pour aller au travail
un tiers est pour tout le reste les
courses les enfants et voir les amis
aller au cinéma quand les cinémas sont
ouverts et c'est donc en gros trois
tiers un tiers domicile travail
un tir mobilité longue qui est surtout
la mobilité de loisirs et un tiers de la
mobilité courte domicile domicile
travail donc ça c'est pour la voiture
et comme je le disais alors l'avion
ma foi là on est clairement dans le
renoncement pur et simple
c'est clair que de ne pas prendre
l'avion c'est renoncer à aller en
argentine aux états unis ou alors vous
prenez un cargo une fois dans votre vie
bon mon père je suis raisonnablement
vieux maintenant mon père qui était donc
encore plus vieux quand il était post
doc il est allé aux états-unis en bateau
donc une époque pas si lointaine que ça
finalement
ou même pour aller dans des contrées
lointaines ne prenez pas là bien donc
et puis si vous avez très envie d'aller
au japon à vous prenez le transsibérien
et donc vous y allez pour six mois avec
un mois
deux trains aller et retour enfin 15
jours à l'aller quinze jours mais sinon
c'est clair que de ne pas prendre
l'avion
c'est une forme de renoncement par
contre pour les déplacements de loisirs
on peut arriver à s'organiser sans
voiture c'est voilà c'est pas
nécessairement plus cher du reste parce
que si vous n'avez pas de voiture
pendant l'année et que vous prenez le
train pour partir en vacances faut faire
le calcul sur l'année je penche sur que
ce soit beaucoup plus cher
et puis dans les déplacements du
quotidien là les règles sont assez
simple c'est avoir la petite voiture
possible l'avoir électrique ne pas avoir
voiture c'est encore mieux et donc le
remplacer par un vélo électrique ou un
vélo tout court
c'est ce qu'on peut faire de mieux bien
évidemment les transports en commun sont
également des bonnes solutions en ce qui
concerne la baisse de l'empreinte
carbone
enfin le dernier quart c'est le logement
le logement plus des services publics
car les services publics on peut pas
dire grand chose c'est 10 % notre
empreinte carbone en france
là dedans vous avez essentiellement
l'hôpital d'enseignement l'armée donc
cédé ces trois postes qui sont fortement
consommateurs d'énergie l'hôpital parce
que c'est une grosse machine
industrielle aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
c'est un gros bâtiments chauffés et
surtout aussi qu'ils consomment
énormément de produits industriels des
médicaments des compresses des seringues
les scalpels des scanners des irm des
chariots pour travailler les malades etc
des respirateurs artificiels en ce
moment bref donc c'est une grosse usine
un hôpital
donc c'est une grosse empreinte carbone
le deuxième poste important c'est
l'armée parce que l'armée utilise des
gros navires et des gros avions
enfin des avions pas si gros mais qui
consomme beaucoup de bruit kérosène et
enfin le troisième poste c'est dans
l'enseignement parce que l'enseignement
possède le premier parc foncier enfin le
premier parc bâti en france et donc vous
avez énormément d'écoles de collèges de
lycées et d'enseignement et de
l'université qui sont chauffés et donc
ça vous fait un aussi une petite partie
du pays dans le logement
bien évidemment c'est le chauffage au
gaz et au fioul
kiko qui est la cause de l'empreinte
carbone du logement ainsi que la
construction neuve parce que la
construction neuve utilise du ciment et
d'acier
et donc quand on construit des logements
et bien en gros il faut compter 300 à
400 kg 200 à 400 kg à l'égard de co2 par
mètre carré construit donc si on
construit une maison de 100 mètres
carrés vous voyez ça fait 20 à 40 tonnes
si vous la construisent et en structure
standard acier et acier béton
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus faible si
vous la construisent et en chambre
pareil tout un tas d'autres d'autres
techniques et si vous utilisez des
pierres ça va vous coûter beaucoup plus
cher puisque le masson va y passer
beaucoup plus de temps mais ça fera une
petite empreinte 15,6 voilà donc
l'essentiel de l'empreinte carbone du
logement c'est le fait de se chauffer
gaz et fuel alors on met souvent en
avant dans ce pays
le chauffage électrique comme étant
l'exemple parfait de la gabegie etc
mais je rappelle quand même qu'il ya en
quantité totale d'énergie quatre fois
plus d'énergie sous forme de gaz et de
fioul utilisé dans ce pays pour le
chauffage que sous forme d'électricité
donc le premier mode de chauffage en
france il est facile de très loin et là
il ya une mesure pas très compliqué mais
qui demande un investissement qui est de
décarbonés le vecteur de chauffage en
passant soit au bois soit la pompe à
chaleur soit en réseau de chaleur si le
réseau de chaleur est alimentée au bois
alors il faut que le bois évidemment
soit renouvelable ce qui veut dire que
il faut qu'ils viennent de forêt dans
lesquelles ça pousse aussi vite que on
le coupe ce qui va devenir un sujet avec
le changement climatique parce que le
changement climatique va obérer la
croissance des forêts ça a déjà commencé
et malheureusement ça n'est que le début
donc voilà c'est une réponse un peu
longue mais du coup j'en ai profité pour
donner quelques quelques éléments de
de visibilité alors il se trouve que
c'est exactement sur ce principe de
l'empreinte carbone qui est fait un
calculateur qui s'appelle maisi ottou
qui a été tout petit peu de pub qui a
été mis en ligne enfin mis en ligne un
petit être qui a été annoncé puis
exactement par carbone 4 il ya quelques
temps alors de précisions ce calculateur
en fait il sera proposé en mode gratuit
pour les particuliers
donc on va avoir un mode un peu
communiste de financement de cette
initiative c'est à dire que les
utilisation en entreprise seront
payantes et les utilisations pour les
particuliers seront gratuites en voilà
donc comme ça ça nous permet d'avoir un
système à double détente qui permettra à
chacun d'aller regarder par contre la
manière dont cet outil a été conçu c'est
qu'on n'a pas souhaité le mettre en
libre accès sans accompagnement donc on
va le diffuser avec quelque chose qui
ressemble à des réunions tupperware un
peu sur le modèle de la fresque du
climat quelque part c'est à dire avec un
système virale donc les premières prises
en main de cette démarche seront
nécessairement dans le cadre de
conférences animées par des gens qui
connaissent un peu histoire que l'on
soit pas seul face à son écran avec l'
envie d'abandonner les envies de se
demander ce qu'on peut faire et c'est
donc on entre tout de suite dans un
dialogue qui permet d'aller de l'avant
donc ce cet outil il est il ya une page
sur le site de carbone 4 qui s'appelle
messi autour vous pouvez aller et on
peut s'il reste de la place
s'inscrire pour les premières versions
les premières versions gratuites et puis
il y en aura d'autres biens bien
évidemment cet outil basé justement sur
le principe de l'empreinte carbone que
je viens de vous décrire avec un système
qui est dépliable c'est à dire qu'en
fonction du temps vous disposez vous
avez des grandes masses où vous pouvez
aller chercher plus précisément dans un
certain nombre de
[Musique]
alors est-ce qu'il vaut mieux être
enterrer ou incinérer
il vaut mieux pas mourir je ne sais pas
je vous avoue que je ne sais pas j'ai
pas fait le j'ai pas fait de calculs
donc je ne sais pas s'ils vont être
enterrées ou un signal par contre ce
dont je suis absolument certain c'est
que avant d'en arriver là il faut
essayer de faire des choses utiles
maintenant on va parler de pognon est ce
que l'argent placé à la banque et
émetteurs de carbone et comment
décarbonés son d'épargnants et bien la
réponse est oui
cet émetteur de carbone alors pourquoi
est-ce que cet émetteur de carbone vous
avez peut-être vu passer cette étude qui
a été publiée par oxfam
il n'y a pas très longtemps sur
l'empreinte carbone des banques et du
reste cette étude d'oxfam a été fait en
utilisant des données qui ont été
fournis par carbon for finance
donc je trouve ça très bien qu'on
travaille à la fois avec un bord et avec
l'autre et en gros le raisonnement est
le suivant
l'empreinte carbone d'une banque c'est
les émissions directes des secteurs ce
n'est pas une définition absolue c'est
la façon dont un quart 24 on a géré le
problème
l'empreinte carbone d'une banque c'est
les émissions directes des secteurs qui
sont financés par la banque alors un
secteur et financé par la banque
si la banque il détient des actions vous
savez que beaucoup de banques ont des
actions qu'elles détiennent pour compte
propre
ça veut dire que c'est des actions
qu'elle possède soit au travers de leur
filiale d' asset management soit au
travers de leurs filiales d'assurance
parce que beaucoup de banques ont des
filiales qui font de l'assurance soit
dans le cadre d'opérations autres et
c'est donc à partir du moment où elles
détiennent des actions où elles
détiennent des obligations c'est à dire
de la dette émise par les entreprises
qu'on peut acheter sur les marchés ou à
partir du moment où elles leur font
crédit comme comment particulière et
bien la façon dont on a considéré à
carbone car ce qu'on allait
comptabiliser contrepartie en terme
d'émissions sceqe on comptabilise les
émissions directes du secteur compte
lens d'accord donc si vous êtes dans une
centrale à charbon une compagnie
aérienne c'est des émissions importantes
si vous êtes dans une compagnie
informatique évidemment c'est des
émissions qui ont beaucoup plus faible
parce que les émissions directes de
capgemini sont ridicules et bien
évidemment dans une société comme ça ce
qui compte c'est les élections
indirectes qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes mais bon c'est la convention
la prise donc une banque elle est
investie dans la totalité de l'économie
parce qu'elles prêtent à peu près à tout
le monde
si vous quelle que soit l'activité que
vous avez là en face si vous demain
matin vous allez dans une agence
bancaire où si vous allez voir un senior
banker si vous êtes une grosse
entreprise vous aurez un crédit donc il
ya très peu de banques qui vont dire non
ça vraiment si vous faites des mines
antipersonnel et si vous faites des
centrales à charbon mais sauf que les
mines antipersonnel c'est tout petit
dans l'économie heureusement et les
centrales à charbon en occident il ya
plus personne qui en fait la plus
personne qui en fait donc donc les
motifs d'exclusion on reste très très
faible alors une fois qu'on a calculé
l'empreinte carbone de la banque
la question c'est à qui commence à se
relier aux particuliers alors c'est très
simple la banque pour être capable de
faire des prêts elle a besoin de ce
qu'on appelle des ressources ses
ressources
c'est tout l'argent qu'elle peut
récolter et qu'elle va pouvoir utiliser
soit pour faire des prêts soit pour
acheter des obligations et des actions
est alors cet argent ces ressources là
dedans il ya notamment les dépôts des
particuliers alors un point important il
faut pas confondre avec ses fonds
propres les fonds propres d'une banque
définissent la quantité d'engagement
qu'une banque est capable de faire c'est
un ratio multiplicatif hook a commencé
un ratio diviseur des ans gars 2 2 de
l'argent vraiment posséder par la banque
et de la quantité de prêts et
d'engagement au sens propre déposition
qu'elle peut prendre sur les marchés de
matières premières etc qu'on l'autorisé
à prendre le
les ressources c'est tous les gens qui
lui ont confié quelque chose alors là
dedans vous avez notamment les dépôts
sur les comptes courants
donc si vous avez un dépôt sur un compte
courant dans une banque vous contribuez
deux fêtes aux ressources de la banque
et ses ressources vont permettre à la
banque d'aller finances et de l'économie
en face et donc de financer des
émissions et donc la façon dont on a
raisonné et c'est comme ça que oxfam a
utilisé le mot donné la façon dont on
arrive donné c'est qu'on ali ben voilà
la personne qui a de l'argent dans une
banque on lui impute au prorata de ses
dépôts sur l'ensemble des ressources de
la banque lésée vision de la banque si
la banque à un total de bilan de 2000
milliards et qu'elle est mais je vais
dire n'importe quoi
200 millions dès que ce tout ça
correspond à 200 millions de tonnes de
co2 si en face vous avez un milliard est
très riche
il avait 1 milliards de dépôts et bien
vous allez récupérer un millième de 200
millions de tonnes dont vous allez
récupérer 200 mille tonnes au titre de
votre empreinte carbone
c'est comme ça qu'on a résonné alors
évidemment comme l'empreinte carbone de
la banque elle est important c'est parce
que la banque finance et des banques ont
des bilans très important bnp paribas
par exemple un total de bilan qui est
lors de deux mille milliards d'euros
c'est à dire un peu moins que le pib
français
évidemment ça c'est un stock le bilan de
bnpp ip est influent enfin oui quand
même que l'on parle de gros de gros
chiffres et bien du coup il ya beaucoup
d'émissions associés alors de l'autre
côté si vous avez juste un peu d'argent
ça vous fait un peu d'émissions mais
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
compte donc dans les marges de manoeuvre
individuelle
il est évident que la façon d'allouer
son épargne est quelque chose qui va
compter de plus en plus allant toujours
dans les initiatives donc je peux vous
parler toujours la même société
capitalistique carbon for finance
ah y'a pas longtemps
conclut enfin devenu partenaire d'une
société qui s'appelle ita et qui est en
train de mettre sur le marché si ce
n'est pas déjà fait un instant une
application utilise aussi nous donner et
qui vous permet de connaître pour 3500
fonds de placement 3200 jeux les plus
fonds de placement qui vous sont
proposés quand vous avez de l'argent
épargné donc vous savez vous allez chez
votre banquier vous allez chez votre
assureur qui vous dit tiens je pourrais
vous proposer tel sicav tel machin intel
etc
c'est ce qu'on appelle des fonds communs
de placement
ces trucs là enfin des fois c'est les
opcvm et enfin le plan porte est bien
lita à reconstituer les les entreprises
dont on détient des obligations et des
actions quand on investit dans ce genre
de choses et les états dans lesquels on
détient des obligations sur les actions
c'est compliqué quand on investit dans
ce genre de choses
donc pour chacun des 3500 font ils ont
reconstitué qu'est ce qu'il y avait
derrière en termes d'actions et
d'obligations et on applique à ses
actions et ses obligations la donne et
qui est issu de la base de données de
carbone finances et ça vous dit ben
voilà tel placement il est plus
carbonées que telle ou placement où il
est moins carboné que tel au classement
voilà donc ça c'est aussi quelque chose
qui permet de jouer avec l'empreinte
carbone de son épargne
après il ya également des marges de
manoeuvre qui sont totalement hors
marché par exemple vous pouvez décider
de mettre votre épargne et dentaire de
liens et à ce moment vous allez servir
enfin votre épargne va servir à
permettre un agriculteur veut s'acheter
de la terre avec évidemment général d
avigdor qui sont bio etc
donc voilà donc il ya plusieurs manières
de
arbitre et là dessus vous pouvez aussi
décider d'investir dans un morceau de
forêt vous aller séquestrer du carbone
si vous vous y prenez bien fait voilà
donc il ya plein de manières de gérer ça
quand on a la chance puisque c'est
toujours une chance d'avoir de l'argent
épargné les deux côtés et bien c'est
clair que la décarbonation de l'epargne
et d'un moyen d'action et c'est un moyen
d'orientation du reste de l'économie
parce que si c'est plus facile
d'emprunter quand vous avez une activité
qui est compatible avec la baisse des
émissions bien évidemment ça oriente
l'économie c'est une grande règle vous
allez contribuer enfin vous allez faire
en sorte que les gens développent plus
facilement des choses qui sont
pertinentes
bien évidemment derrière tout ça il ya
un sujet qui est absolument essentiel
qui est sujet de la méthode
parce que là j'ai pas arrêté dit on peut
décarbonés l'économie comme si enfin
décarbonés les parle comme si la méthode
utilisée pour apprécier la décarbonation
de son épargne était un truc évident je
vous dis tout à leur nom dans la
convention qu'on a utilisées pour les
banques à carbone car c'est une
convention pour rien à voir une autre
voilà on pense que celle là est pas
idiote b rien à boire une eau et donc le
diable va être dans les détails
et donc aujourd'hui à linverse vous avez
plein de produits d'épargné qui vous
sont proposés qui sont dits et sert
quand vous allez regarder un peu dans le
détail qui sont pas plaider carbone
entre les autres d'abord parce que lee
et sert peut très bien avoir un objectif
il n'a rien à voir avec le climat
aujourd'hui dans l'est dans les serres
on considère souvent que les objectifs
sont sont visibles si je suis pas
terrible sur le climat mais que je suis
bon sur les handicapés et l'égalité
hommes femmes alors ça va bien j'ai au
total une bonne note
bah moi je considère que non à partir du
moment où vous êtes mauvais sur le
climat de toute façon on court à notre
perte suit envie de dire savoir si vous
êtes bon sur le reste devient un peu
sans objet il faut c'est passé pas c'est
pas une option
il faut être bon sur le sur le climat
donc il ya un vrai sujet de méthode et
malheureusement il ya un coût d'entrée
là dedans c'est à dire que les gens qui
vont vouloir avoir
un comportement vertueux entre
guillemets sur la façon d'allier leur
épargne il ya un coût d'entrée là dedans
il faudra malheureusement vous y passer
un peu de temps pour comprendre ce qui
va se passer
il ya un dernier point qu'un jour
j'aurais dû en parler aussi parce que
c'est encore un client de ces quatre il
ya des gens qui commencent à
s'intéresser à l'épargné salariale et à
la façon de proposer pour les peindre
salariale donc vous savez qu'il ya une
épargne salariale notamment au travers
de l'investissement de l'intéressement
l'état notamment au travers de
l'intéressement et l'intéressement
aujourd'hui si vous choisissez de le
placer via les supports qui sont
proposés par une entreprise très souvent
ça va être géré j'ai envie de dire de
façon normale c'est à dire que on va
vous coller quelque chose qui ressemble
en termes de profil de placement à ce
que vous avez dans votre assurance vie
ordinaire eh bien il ya des gens qui
commencent à proposer ou à essayer de
proposer des produits qui sont là aussi
décarbonée donc ça rentre quand même
dans tendance est un sanglier cerf mais
décarbonés sur l' épargne salariale donc
quand vous touchez votre intéressement
vous avez la possibilité de mettre ça
dans des produits pour lesquels les gens
qui composent les produits considèrent
qu'ils ont fait le plus attention que
les autres au fait que ce soit
compatible avec une économie bas carbone
voilà là aussi ça demande un petit peu
de temps pour aller regarder d'un peu
près ce qu'il ya dedans et pour vérifier
que enfin pour vérifier pour accepter
plutôt vérifier que la méthode utilisée
vous semble pertinente qu'elle est
qu'elle est bonne quelle est en lien
avec ce que lorsque ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure
voilà alors après il ya une question
dont je ne me rappelle plus
[Musique]
mais qui était la question de l'emploi
dit autrement est une des actions
importantes qu'on peut faire également à
titre personnel n'est pas de changer de
métier alors la réponse est bien
évidemment que c'est quelque chose
d'important si on y arrive
alors il ya deux manières en fait d'agir
individuellement au travers de
l'activité vous puissez sap de manière
il ya une première manière qui est de
changer de métier alors ça c'est quelque
chose que l'on voit très souvent
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens se disent ah ben tiens
j'ai pas envie de rester là où je suis
je voudrais aller ailleurs et faire
autre chose il ya le choix du premier
métier qui peut être orienté également
par cette considération
j'ai aujourd'hui il n'est en est un
mystère pour aucun étudiant normalement
qu' il existe une association qui
s'appelle le manifeste par une
association oui en fait un mouvement on
va dire qui s'appelle le manifeste des
étudiants pour la réveiller écologique
qui est notamment composée d'étudiants
qui déclare qu' il ne souhaite pas aller
travailler pour des gens qui traitent le
problème climatique et énergétique et
environnementale plus largement par
dessus la jambe
c'est pas une majorité je ne pense pas
que ce soit une majorité d'étudiants en
france mais il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits où c'est la majorité pas loin
de la majorité
ou alors après il faut voir si c'est une
déclaration qui a été faite par
l'étudiant ou l'étudiante
un soir de beuverie et 100 séquences ou
six aimé mais il ya quelque chose là
derrière donc on peut choisir son métier
bien évidemment en essayant de faire en
sorte qu'ils soient en accord avec ce à
quoi on prend le problème il est
beaucoup plus une fois qu'on croit à
quelque chose et qu'on a envie de
changer de métier alors c'est facile ou
c'est pas facile des fois c'est facile
des fois non et puis enfin la troisième
chose qu'on peut faire c'est militer à
l'intérieur de son entreprise pour que
son entreprise où on ne change pas de
métier deviennent un peu plus sérieuses
sur la question
alors ça aussi on commence à le voir
arriver sous des formes très diverses
par exemple
au sein d'orange il ya eu il ya pas
longtemps un ensemble de salariés qui se
sont manifestés pour dire qu'il pensait
qu'il n'était pas pertinent de faire le
déploiement de la 5g au motif que 7,5 g
n'avait pas un bilan avantages
inconvénients qui était pertinent et
notamment il y avait trop
d'inconvénients sur le plan
environnemental pour les avantages que
ça allait nous procurer bon c'est
inutile de vous dire que c'est pas ça
qui a ralenti le cours de l'histoire
c'est quand même le signe qu' il ya des
gens qui peuvent décider d'agir au
travers de leur profession et c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a de
l'importance à l'intérieur de leur
entreprise ça aussi de l'importance pour
une autre raison c'est que je les ai dit
tout à l'heure quand on commence à
vouloir agir un truc qui est très
important c'est de ne pas être seul
c'est on a besoin d'être dans un
collectif de fer communauté quand on me
le passer à l'action et au sein d'une
entreprise on est a priori rassemblés
avec des gens avec qui on partage déjà
une première chose qui est le métier
qu'on fait donc si on arrive à partager
une deuxième chose qui est une
préoccupation écologique du coup ça
donne du coeur j'ai envie de dire
et donc c'est un cadre dans lequel on
peut avoir plus facilement envie d'agir
que dans son cadre individuel non pas
que dans le cadre individuel on soit
prisonnier de son confort mais comme je
le disais tout à l'heure on peut être
lié à une cellule familiale ou à une
cellule sociale qui fait que c'est pas
simple de passer à l'action parce que le
coût affectif et quelque part supérieure
au coût matériel alors que dans une
entreprise bas ça peut éventuellement
être paradoxalement éventuellement être
plus simple par ailleurs dans
l'entreprise il ya des moyens souvent
pour faire autrement parce que j'ai
envie de dire on a toujours une petite
zone dans l'entreprise où l'on maîtrise
à peu près ce qu'on fait elle peut être
plus ou moins importantes il ya toujours
rien donc le donc dans les actions
individuelles
il me semble que la façon d'exercer son
métier et la façon éventuellement soin
d'en changer
soit 2 d'essayer de faire en sorte que
l'organisme dans lequel on échange ses
pratiques c'est une action qui est pas
du tout anodine
et qu'il faut aussi avoir en tête de
façon permanente
j'ai envie de dire changeons totalement
de sujets pour ceux qui doivent quand
même avoir une voiture vous l'endroit où
ils vivent à quel est le meilleur choix
de motorisation est ce que c'est diesel
essence gaz hybride électrique alors il
ya une autre
il ya une autre question qui peut être
rattaché à cela qui est est-ce qu'il
faut nécessairement changer de voiture
quand on a une voiture dont on se sert
pas beaucoup étaient anciennes alors
paradoxalement la réponse à cette
deuxième question est nécessairement oui
si vous n'êtes pas ce que pour faire une
voiture
en gros il va falloir ramener à la durée
de vie de la voiture et m entre allez on
va dire de l'ordre de 30 grammes de co2
par km pour une voiture qui n'est pas
une grosse voiture
donc ça veut dire que 30 grammes de co2
au kilomètre si vous avez une voiture
qui est déjà totalement amorti dont vous
vous servez pas beaucoup ça vaut pas
nécessairement le coup s'il faut il faut
réfléchir si vous vous en servez 2000 ou
3000 km par an ça vaut pas
nécessairement le coup en particulier
d'acheter une voiture électrique dont
l'amortissement ou km va être de 60 ou
70 g entre la fabrication de la voiture
et la fabrication de la batterie voilà
mais il faut vraiment pas beaucoup s'en
servir et puis il faut être sûr que la
voiture que vous allez changer par bien
la casse parce que si elle par ailleurs
en fait vous allez motorisés quelqu'un
je donc à votre question c'est pourquoi
je la remplace si je suis à la campagne
la meilleure motorisations possibles
celle électrique un très clairement à la
campagne et du reste c'est aujourd'hui
le premier segment de vente des zoé au
moment où renault a commencé à
commercialiser ses véhicules électriques
renault s'était dit que ça allait être
une deuxième voiture d'urbain est en
fait c'est souvent une première voiture
ou une deuxième mais c'est une voiture
principale j'ai envie de dire de gens
qui habitent en milieu rural parce que
ils n'ont pas de problème pour la
recharger chez eux ils n'ont pas de
problème pour la recharger à destination
ils font moins de toute façon chez eux
ils font moins de 200 kilomètres dans la
journée donc mais qui la recherchent pas
destination ce programme et ça leur
coûte beaucoup moins cher pour des gens
qui font vingt ou trente mille
kilomètres dans l'année qu'une voiture à
essence
donc si vous êtes à la campagne
clairement pour remplacer une voiture à
une voiture à essence ou une voiture à
dix elle la meilleure idée
c'est une voiture électrique après si
vous êtes à la campagne et que vous avez
quand même beaucoup de petits
déplacements à faire en complément de sa
vous pouvez acheter un vélo électrique
parce que la batterie d'un vélo est 100
fois plus petites que la batterie une
voiture donc les émissions de
fabrication sont cent fois plus petit et
avec un vélo électrique on peut faire
raisonnablement 10 ou 15 km dans la
journée sans vraiment sans problème au
sens de on souffre pas moi je suis très
frappé
j'habite en banlieue parisienne je suis
très frappé de voir le nombre de gens
qu'on voit aujourd'hui circuler en vélo
électrique qui ont absolument pas des
profils de rang sportif et dont on se
dit que s'il n'y avait pas eu
l'électricité sur le vélo j'avais il se
serait mis à ce mode de déplacement
alors malheureusement entre guillemets
aujourd'hui une bonne partie de cet
essor vient en remplacement des
transports en commun donc qui était déjà
à décarbonée mais il y en a une partie
qui vient aussi en remplacement de la
voiture et sarah évidemment c'est une
très bonne chose à faire sur la baisse
de l'empreinte carbone et la baisse des
émissions
voilà donc le
la réponse est aussi vraiment vous devez
avoir une voiture à la compagnie ces
voitures électriques sans hésitation et
si vous avez la possibilité en plus de
faire une partie des trajets à vélo
c'est parfait alors oui donc y avait une
question sur l'analyse de cycle de vie
des analyses de cycle de vie sur les
batteries oui il y en a alors détaillé
non il y en a pas sur le bilan carbone
des voitures électriques mais avec les
grandes masses vous avez 44 par exemple
a publié un document là dessus que que
vous pouvez que vous pouvez facilement
trouver alors revenons aux achats quid
du rétrofit demande dont le retrofit
c'est comme si on faisait une voiture
électrique neuf c'est à dire qu'on va
vous mettre un moteur électrique et les
batteries donc ça évite le châssis ça
évite la voiture donc ce que j'ai envie
de dire si sa vie aussi longtemps qu'une
voiture neuve sur la partie moteur
électrique et batterie c'est une encore
meilleure idée puisque vous récupérez
châssis on va passer maintenant ou you
cas du carbone dont il ya une question
qui a été posée sur escales une
application qui permet de scanner les
produits alors là il parle de du bilan
carbone de chaque produit de
consommation alors figurez vous qu'au
moment du grenelle de l'environnement
cette idée avait été émise et puis elle
s'avère en pratique très difficile à
mettre en oeuvre je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
quand vous avez un produit qu'il ya un
prix par exemple l'ordinateur que je
suis en train d'utiliser en ce moment un
prix pull que je porte sur moi avait
appris quand je les achetais ce prix
existe parce que tout le long de la
chaîne de valeur qui va de l'extraction
des matières premières jusqu'aux prendre
j'ai acheté il y à une comptabilité qui
est tenue rentabilité monétaire qui est
tenu par chaque acteur de la chaîne donc
chaque acteur de la chaîne tient un
dispositif complet qui s'appelle à une
comptabilité monétaire dans laquelle il
inventorie la totalité de ce qui
rendrait la totalité de ce qui sort de
son entreprise et ils passent
l'information à l'élément suivant de la
chaîne de valeur sous forme de prix des
produits intermédiaires donc par exemple
la personne qui a planté le coton
eh bien elle passe au suivant alors le
plan se publie magie ne prenant pas de
prendre l'avion qui est en coton donc le
planteurs de coton il a passé d'abord il
a reçu des gens qui vendent des machines
pour planter les cotons et des prix il a
tenu une comptabilité et à partir de
cette comptabilité
il a établi un prix de vente de la balle
de golf dont qu'il donne aux acteurs
suivants de la chaîne qui va faire des
fields en coton et lui c'est pareil cas
une comptabilité avec des salaires des
amortissements des loyers etc
il va passer derrière le prix d'un fil
de coton à des gens qui étaient et donc
à l'arrivée
moi pour ma chemise j'ai un prix mais en
fait ce prix il intègre tout ce qui
s'est passé à l'amont sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne de valeur depuis les matières
premières alors si on voulait avoir un
prix carbone pour ma chemise
il faudrait faire exactement pareil
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait que le
planteurs de coton située en inde aux
états unis où je sais pas où il a une
comptabilité car de carbone pardon
intégral qu'il passerait cette
comptabilité enfin vous y passerez le
contenu carbone de tout ce qu'il vend
aux gens qui achètent son coton pour
faire des fils qui eux même pas ce
qu'est le compte du quart et c'est donc
en fait pour avoir le contenu carbone de
tous produits disponibles à la vente
il faudrait que toutes les entreprises
dans le monde et une comptabilité
carbone alors vous allez me dire
évidemment que ça n'existe pas à ce
moment vous allez lire les commantaires
bonne carte fait pour faire son métier
alors que ça n'existe pas alors la
réponse est on fait des approximations
donc dans le domaine de la comptabilité
carbone
on passe son temps à faire des
approximations c'est pour ça que c'est
des démarches qui sont individualisés à
chaque fois parce que le système
n'existe pas en presse-bouton avec
toutes entreprises dans le monde qui
tiendrait en permanence sa comptabilité
carbone qui lui permettrait d'avoir en
permanence le contenu carbone de
absolument tout ce qu'elle fait tout ça
chez nez avec toutes les autres
entreprises dans le monde et des
administrations etc
alors comme je pense que je mourrais
sens on voit ce système hébergé de façon
complète je pense que ça va être très
très difficile de faire émerger un
étiquetage carbone qu'ils soient un peu
sensé sur les produits parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans les magasins vous
pouvez acheter
enfin sauf les libraires les pompes mais
enfin orco vide
on peut acheter des centaines de
milliers de produits différents dans les
magasins et si on veut que cet
étiquetage carbone servent à quelque
chose
il faut bien évidemment que cette
chemise elle est pas le même prix
carbone entre guillemets que chemise
qu'ils aient ressemble qui est proposée
juste à côté parce que sinon c'est pas
un élément de choix si je dis ben voila
je fais la cv d'une chemise en coton de
façon standard et à ce moment toutes les
chemises en coton auront exactement le
même port carbone vous comprenez bien
que c'est le différencie absolument pas
quelqu'un qui a fait du coton cultivé
comme ceux ci et qui a tissé simplement
avec des gens qui poussaient des roues
et versus quelqu'un d'autre qui a
utilisé d'électricité au charbon
vous n'arrivez pas à le distinguer donc
vous êtes obligé si vous voulez vraiment
distinguer chaque chemise chaque chaque
pantalons etc
vous êtes vraiment obligé d'avoir chaque
entreprise dans le monde qui fasse sa
comptabilité carbone une blague que je
fais souvent à ce propos est de dire que
les entreprises deviendront sérieuse sur
le carbone
le jour au carbone 4 fera la taille de
watts c'est alors je pas du tout notre
ambition est juste pour dire que c'est
pour illustrer l'importance de la
comptabilité monétaire dans la vie des
entreprises est temps que la
comptabilité carbone ne sera pas
importante à quelque chose qui a
peut-être pas au même niveau mais pas
loin
quelque chose qui ressemble et bien il
ne sera pas possible d'avoir un prix
carbone ou un point carbon individualisé
par produit incidemment ce que je viens
de vous dire sur les produits
manufacturés est également valable en ce
qui concerne les produits financiers
donc ce que je vous dis ce que je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure sur l'empreinte
carbone de l'epargne c'est aussi quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui est établi avec
des ratios des approximations ira donc
c'est beaucoup mieux que rien ça permet
quand même de faire des vrais
différenciation y compris entre
entreprises mais ça reste quelque chose
qui est moins précis que si chaque
entreprise
encore une fois tenait sa comptabilité
carbone donc pour avoir le yucca du
carbone il faudra attendre dans
arrivé là où il faudra attendre qu'un
bis ex quelconque donne 30 milliards de
dollars parce que vraiment beaucoup
d'argent à des gens qui vont être
capables de reconstituer sa en
permanence pour l'ensemble des produits
du monde en faisant les calculs de leur
côté mais dans le contexte actuel
encore une fois on peut on peut pas y
arriver
ce qu'on peut avoir encore une fois
c'est ce que je vous ai évoqué tout à
l'heure avec la part de chaque fin de
chaque grande catégorie dans l'empreinte
carbone et le fait que bien évidemment
on sait différencier l'ordre de grandeur
d'un kilo de boeuf par rapport un kilo
de blettes par rapport à 1 kg de patates
voilà ça on sait mais entre le contenu
carbone précis des patates qui sont
disponibles chez un vendeur à au marché
et chez un vendeur bo marché et chez un
vendeur c'est au marché pour avoir ça il
faudrait que la totalité de l'économie
face une comptabilité carbone
voilà ça le c1 ce degré de détails
aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de
varier alors après qu'est ce que j'avais
vu d'autres comme question que je
trouvais rigolote 1
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il faut favoriser le chauffage
au bois ça j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
tant que le bois est renouvelable oui et
il faut avoir un poil qui ne fasse pas
de particules fines donc il faut avoir
un poil efficace sinon ça fait une
grosse cigarette -un pour le poum poum à
léger rebond à ces questions
intéressantes l'effet rebond
comment est-ce qu'on limite les firmes
gonds alors en fait la question je la
prends pour l'individu et alors je la
rapproche d'une autre question qui a été
posée que j'ai trouvé intéressante qui
est bon très bien je gagne ce que je
gagne donc je vais me limiter sur les
achats je vais visibilité sur la viande
gemini vite et sur l'avion etc
à l'arrivée du coup je vais me limiter
sur les dépenses donc il me reste du
pognon qu'est-ce que j'en fais alors
c'est une très bonne question parce et
en fait ça se rapproche de l'effet
rebond à partir du moment où vous avez
une logique budgétaire pour votre
dépendance que ce soit la dépense
monétaire où la dépense carbone enfin
quand je dis vous moi une importe qu'ils
ont il est évident que si on arrive à se
restreindre sur certains postes mais
qu'on continue à dépenser autant on aura
simplement reporté les émissions et la
dépense sur d'autres postes dont on ne
tenait pas compte avant donc il ya la
seule bonne manière
d'y arriver c'est alors je vais dire des
choses horribles une première c'est
accepter de gagner moins comme ça on est
sûr on n'a pas le problème de la
dépendance une deuxième c'est de faire
comme gainsbourg c'est à dire de se
mettre devant un écran de télé de
briller de brûler des billets de 500
euros
ce qui revient à gagner après on peut
quand même essayer comme je le disais
tout à l'heure
d'utiliser cet argent pour des
investissements de la transition ça j'ai
envie de dire que c'est quand même une
solution qui paraît pas idiote où on
peut aussi et alors ça c'est quelque
chose qui est une marge de manoeuvre
importante accepté d'acheter moins et de
payer plus cher est alors souvent quand
on achète moins et qu'on paye plus cher
on va se retrouver avec des produits
dans lesquels la part de main d'oeuvre a
augmenté
je vous donne un exemple idiots qui est
le vin à boire avec modération
et bien si vous achetez une bouteille de
entre guillemets mauvais vin pas
terrible vous allez avoir une bouteille
qui a un contenu carbone plus faible que
si vous achetez un grand vin donc un
grand vin il y aura plus de carbone par
bouteille mais il y aura moins de
carbone par auront donc si vous avez un
budget vin que vous voulez dépenser dans
l'année comme dans la neva voilà je
dépense 300 euros de bouteilles de vin
et bien vous avez intérêt à acheter des
bouteilles de vin qui sont chères parce
que vous allez en vous allez avoir une
empreinte carbone plus basse pour
votre consommation de vin sauf si
derrière vous tamponné la bagnole et
voulait racheter bon sinon vous avez une
combine carbone plus basse et ça revient
à dire que vous allez acheter du vin
dans lequel par euros il ya une part de
main d'oeuvre qui est plus importante
voilà ça revient ça revient à dire ça
donc c'est un point qui ce que ce que je
viens de dire
peut être peut être reproduit dans
certains secteurs mais pas dans l'autre
par exemple si vous achetez un
ordinateur plus cher vous n'allez pas
acheter un ordinateur avec moins de
carbone par euros vous allez acheter un
ordinateur avec une empreinte carbone
plus élevé donc ça marche pas à tous les
coups mais parce que le carbone par
euros sera un peu près le même mais il
ya des domaines dans lesquels ça marche
ça marche également avec tout ce qui est
par exemple confectionner main dans les
vêtements ça marche avec le fait que par
exemple votre budget vêtement si vous la
loue et non pas à remplacer les
vêtements mais aller chez la couturière
chez les couturiers pour que on vous
reprennent beaux vêtements enfin bon les
reprennent au sens où on voulait réparé
barre à ce moment vous allez convertir
un budget fabrication en un budget
réparation qui est toujours beaucoup
moins chargée en carbone parce qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de main d'oeuvre
voilà donc il ya des manières d'arbitré
sa dépense est la règle en général qui
vous donnera le chemin vers la lumière
c'est la règle qui consiste à
privilégier des produits dans lesquels
il ya une part de main d'oeuvre plus
importante c'est également c'est exact
c'est exactement pour la même raison que
vous allez trouver pour certains
produits agricoles des produits qui sont
plus chers
tout en étant de meilleure qualité au
kilo souvent vous aurez une part de main
d'oeuvre en plus importante
dans ces produits donc pour les produits
j'ai envie de dire qu'ils ont un prix au
kilo ce qui peut concerner les vêtements
et bien vous vous rendrez compte que la
règle que je viens d'évoquer est une
règle qui souvent fonctionne bien quand
vous avez des produits qui sont
unitairement plus cher vous allez par
construction limiter votre budget et
favoriser des produits dans lesquels la
part de madame la plus importante alors
alors
baum un boom sa pensée on n'a pas
d'actions individuelles là à 7 e concert
n'a pas tout ça ça concerne des pales
individuelles dont je vais revenir à
acheter en amazonie dans un supermarché
ça c'est une question qu'on filme
enceinte on pourrait penser que le fait
d'acheter avec des gens qui vous livre
sa une empreinte carbone plus faibles en
gros si vous allez au supermarché ou
plus encore à l'hypermarché
chacun prend sa voiture pour y aller
alors que si vous achetez des choses qui
sont livré chez vous vous avez un seul
camion qui fait la tournée tout le monde
alors c'est vrai si ça marche bien sauf
que en pratique souvent ça marche pas
bien parce que quand amazon passe chez
vous eh bien vous avez vous n'êtes pas
là donc vous avez un avis qui vous ai
laissé dans votre boîte à lettres et
après il faut que le livreur repasse
donc en fait vous avez énormément de
ratés dans la
livraison à domicile qui fait que ça
peut contribuer à augmenter l'empreinte
carbone de ce mode de distribution
après vous avez un deuxième effet alors
qu'il est pas directement liées au mode
de distribution
mais qui lit et aux pratiques
commerciales qui sont associés à ce type
de distribution alors par amazon c'est
plutôt d'autres sites
mais si vous allez dans un supermarché
acheter un kilo de carottes ou même une
paire de chaussures
si les chaussures ne voulons pas vous
allez pas retourner au supermarché en
disant que finalement je l'ait fait
changer ça marche bien alors que vous
avez plein de sites de commerce en ligne
sur lesquels vous acheter des chaussures
elles voudront pas voulait renvoyer vous
en recommander deuxième paire voulons
pas vous les renvoyer et c'est donc en
fait vous avez un effet rebond assez
significatif sur la vente en ligne liée
au fait que vous pouvez renvoyer le
produit dont vous n'êtes pas contents
donc en pratique les modes d'achat sur
les sites en ligne ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes que ceux qu'ils
sont dans un magasin physique là la
troisième chose c'est que après vous
avez quand même beaucoup de supermarchés
de plus en plus où les gens vont sans
voiture j'ai envie de dire vous avez des
supermarchés des surfaces commerciales
qui se débrouille pour être accessible à
pied ou en transports en commun et ainsi
d'avancer dans ces surfaces là que ça
résiste le mieux quand l'économie va pas
bien on avait il ya très très longtemps
c'est une analyse à 44 où on avait
constaté que quand l'économie va pas
bien c'est les hypermarchés qui
souffrent en premier parce qu'à ce
moment là les gens restreignent leurs
déplacements en voiture et donc il ya un
certain nombre d'achats qu'ils font
moins souvent et comme ils le font moins
souvent ils les font moins souvent c'est
à dire qu'ils n'achètent pas plus au
moment où ils achètent justice en
achètent moins souvent et vous
remarquerez que au moment où l'économie
c'est vise à souffrir après la crise des
subprimes c'est les distributeurs qui
étaient les plus investis dans les
grands formats hypermarchés qui ont le
plus souffert
parce que c'est là que vous avez le plus
de déplacements induits en donc
maintenant entre le commerce physique et
le commerce sur amazon vous dit j'ai pas
fait léger pas fait les calculs de
manière de manière précise voilà j'ai
envie de vous dire c est ni l'un ni
l'autre
achetez donc dans un allez donc dans un
endroit où vous pouvez aller à pied si
vous avez cette possibilité et si
vraiment vous devez y aller en voiture à
ce moment ça renvoie à la question
précédente qui est essayé d'y aller en
voiture électrique ou en voiture à
plusieurs ou en vélo avec une carriole à
est ce qu'il ya il ya un la question de
l'isolation des logements dans un monde
qui se réchauffe de manière
significative
alors j'en ai un tout petit peu parlé
tout à l'heure je vais y revenir dans un
monde qui se réchauffe de manière
significative
il va se passer deux choses d'abord le
besoins en chauffage va un peu baisser à
temps
il va pas disparaître c'est pas parce
que le monde se réchauffe qu' on va
arrêter d'avoir des hivers en tout cas
pas en france donc même si l'hiver il
est quelques degrés plus chaud que
l'hiver qu'on avait l'habitude d'avoir
eh bien ça reste quand même inférieure à
20 degrés et donc il va falloir du
courage mais à côté de ça on va avoir
des épisodes show de plus en plus
fréquents et des épisodes même très
chaud et donc ça vaut le coup également
de se poser la question de savoir s'il
faut pas protéger les habitats contre le
show à la réponse est évidemment oui
il ya plusieurs manières de protéger les
habitats quand le show la première alors
elle n'a rien à voir avec la performance
thermique de l'envelope elle consiste
tout simplement à multiplier les
surfaces blanches
vous savez que l'habitat par exemple
dans les endroits où il fait chaud il
est facilement blanc y compris les toits
alors aujourd'hui on trouve ça très
étonnant d'avoir des murs et des toits
blancs entre les murs pas trop et les
toits blancs mais peut-être que ce sera
une des premières choses intelligentes à
faire dans un monde qui va connaître de
plus en plus d'épisodes d'épisodes chaud
et en particulier qui seront
particulièrement dure à vivre en ville
la deuxième chose qu'on peut faire pour
l'isolation contre le show s'est alors
ça c'est une mesure qui est très urbaine
c'est de mettre des arbres à supposer
qu'ils aient toujours assez d'eau pour
pousser parce que les arbres ont un
double effet kiss cool
le premier c'est que il empêche le
rayonnement solaire de chauffer la
surface urbaine de chauffer le bitume et
ils ont un deuxième effet kiss cool qui
est que l'évaporation d'eau qu'ils
occasionnent
mais encore faut-il qu'ils peuvent de
temps en temps permet de refroidir la
surface parce que l'évaporation est une
évacuation de chaleur exactement comme
la transpiration sur l'accord après si
on touche à l'enveloppent bien des
valeurs en ce moment on va se retrouver
avec les mêmes marges de manoeuvre que
pour l'isolation qu'on peu froid c'est à
dire que par exemple avoir un toit avec
une très grosse épaisseur en laine de
verre
ça permet d'isoler contre le froid
l'hiver et ça permet d'isoler canton le
chaud l'été
voilà c
et à voir les deux parce que à partir du
moment où la conductivité thermique de
l'envelope diminue diminué dans le sens
de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur en hiver
mais elle diminue dans le sens de
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur en été même
motif même punition
il ya également des des mesures qui
peuvent être prises avec des enfants
quand vous avez des fenêtres qui sont
situés plein sud c'est intéressant pour
l'hiver c'est moins intéressant pour
l'été à ce moment on peut mettre des
auvents et les auvents ça permet de
masquer le soleil sur les ouvertures
quand on l été et ça ne le gêne pas
quand on est l'hiver voilà donc ça peut
faire également partie des marges de
manoeuvre que peu qu'on peut appliquer
mais il est clair que aujourd'hui on va
devoir de plus en plus combiner les deux
enfin sur le vecteur de chauffage vous
avez aujourd'hui je parlais tout à
l'heure de la pompe à chaleur
vous avez des pompes à chaleur qui sont
réversibles
c'est à dire qu'elles sont capables de
faire du chaud l'hiver et du froid l'été
et danse dans cette catégorie là la
pompe à chaleur qui est particulièrement
intéressante c'est la pompe à chaleur
géothermique
c'est à dire que l'hiver est d'aller
chercher les calories dans le sol et non
pas dans leur palais pas aller au
thermique et l'été elle remet les
calories dans le sol
de telle sorte que vous avez un système
de va et vient entre l'hiver et l'été et
le stockage de chaleur dans le sol et un
truc qui marche assez bien ça vous fait
pour monter le sol de 30 degrés ça vous
le fait monter de quelques degrés baisse
et c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
raisonnablement efficace vous avez
également en version or clim ce qu'on
appelle le puits canadien
c'est à dire une circulation d'air dans
le sous sol qui permet de préchauffer
l'air l'hiver et de le pré refroidir
l'été vous avez un certain nombre de ça
évidemment ça marche bien dans la maison
individuelle ça marche pas dans
l'habitat collectif
donc oui la réponse il va falloir se
préoccuper à partir de maintenant
de façon importante de l'isolation de
l'isolation contre le show est ce que ça
va permettre de réduire la consommation
d'énergie si vous mettez une clim oui si
vous en mettez pardon ça va simplement
vous permettre de géants vie dire de
passer les périodes très chaude dans des
conditions un peu moins inconfortable
sachant que l'intérieur trop chaude non
pas comme inconvénient que de faire des
canicules dans les villes bien
évidemment ça va également comment dire
nuire aux forêts nuire aux cultures
nuire aux débits des cours d'eau
voilà un tas d'autres inconvénients mais
enfin qui ne relèvent pas à ce stade de
l'action individuelle et sur la partie
logement
oui il va falloir s'occuper de s'occuper
de ça je rappelle une chose que
normalement beaucoup de gens qui
regardent connaissent c'est que comme le
climat maintenant les parties pour
dériver quoi qu'on fasse
jusqu'à la fin des temps historiques
plus ou moins importante de façon plus
ou moins importante mais il va le faire
de toute façon
eh bien il ya un certain nombre de
modifications des logements qu'il faut
faire et le plus tôt ou six le plus tôt
on s'y met et le million de porte quoi
ça notamment par le faux contre des
conditions qui sont qui seront
progressivement de plus en plus de plus
en plus chaudes
parlons d'agriculture il ya un
agriculteur qui veut dire en tant que
futurs jeunes agriculteurs comment
puisse piloter l'impact carbone de mon
exploitation
quelles sont les meilleures stratégies à
mettre en oeuvre
alors il ya la question de l'agriculture
et des émissions est une question très
intéressante parce que l'agriculture est
un des rares secteurs économiques qui
puisse à la fois maîtres et séquestré
aujourd'hui l'agriculture est
essentiellement une source d'émissions
alors à l'échelle planétaire c'est une
source d'émissions
d'abord à cause de la déforestation j'en
ai parlé tout à l'heure qui est une
processus amont de la mise en culture de
surface qui avant étaient couvertes par
des forêts
puis au moment des cultures vous avez un
certain nombre de pratiques qui
conduisent à des émissions d'abord le
labourage de la terre
dans les premières jamais une décennie
d'exploitation du champ est également un
processus qui conduit à des émissions
parce que ça oxydes ça conduit le
carbone qui est contenue dans le sol
sous forme du bus à être oxydé par
l'oxygène de l'air et donc à passer sous
forme de co2 dans l'atmosphère
ensuite vous avez évidemment l'énergie
des engins salud et à l'heure vous avez
la fabrication des anglais tout ça ça
alors c'est bon ca y contribuer mais une
partie de ce processus il peut être
renversée et notamment dans le domaine
agricole
il ya des pratiques aujourd'hui qui
permettent de remettre du carbone dans
le sol
vous avez par exemple les pratiques qui
sont dites sans labour donc à ce moment
vous ne laboure et plus la terre vous se
met directement sur le couvert végétal
qu'ils sont des plantes qui vous
intéressait pas pour être mangés alors
le seul problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui font ça ils
utilisent un herbicide au moment où ils
s'aiment pour tuer les cultures
confèrent les plans de concurrentes
en gros il liste les plantes
concurrentes moi j'ai pas envie de les
voir ce que je veux c'est que il pousse
du blé donc au moment où ils sèment le
blé sans labour évidemment ce qui est
bon pour le carbone à ce moment cra qui
passe un couple qui fera date
question est-ce que c'est mieux que de
labourer et de pas mettre de glyphosate
ben c'est une question difficile pas pas
évidente du tout qui aujourd'hui
bénéficient d'un traitement médiatique
qui est un peu trop simpliste comme
beaucoup de questions compliquées
c'est pas évident en tout cas c'est une
question qui doit se regarder à peu près
mais donc on peut faire de la culture
sans labour on peut encourager
l'agroforesterie l'agroforesterie
consiste à refaire des haies et des
arbres qui sont conjoints mixte continue
aux cultures alors ça aussi s'armer du
carbone dans le sol parce que vous avez
les racines des arbres les racines des
grands maîtres du carbone dans le sol et
par ailleurs sa présente d'autres
avantages parce que les feuilles des
arbres et les failles des aides peuvent
servir d'amendement organique
c'est comme la paille tombe sur le sol
et puis après les vers de terre
bouffe et on est au fond du bus
éventuellement dans les endroits où on
commence à avoir des problèmes de trop
d'insolation l'été ça fait un peu
d'ombré
et puis ça permet également de mieux
retenir l'eau parce que l'eau ruisselle
- quantel et racines que quand elle est
survenue voilà donc il ya un certain
nombre d'avantagés à faire ce genre de
choses on a fait sauter les arbres dans
les champs en france tout simplement au
moment où on a mécanisé les cultures
parce que ça permettait d'être plus
efficace avec les passages de tracteurs
si vous avez des parcelle de cinq
hectares
c'est plus compliqué que vous devez
faire le tour à chaque fois de la
parcelle est l'autre acteur vous mettez
plus de temps que s'il ya plus de plus
de l est que vous avez une parcelle de
100 de 202 500 hectares donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a fait sauter
les partout mais aujourd'hui il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui considèrent
que ce n'était pas une bonne idée
d'avoir fait ça et qu'il faut revenir
quelque part un paysage qui rend sans
plus et du bocage
voilà le dernier dernier intérêt de
faire ce genre de choses alors c'est pas
directement carbone ça mais c'est
intéressant quand même c'est que les
elles peuvent servir d'habitat pour un
certain nombre de bestioles qui ensuite
se feront un plaisir d'aller bouffer les
pucerons et des larves de papillons
contre lesquels les agriculteurs
utilisent des insecticides
donc c'est donc voilà donc ce que j'ai
envie de dire le grand sujet carbone
en ce qui concerne les exploitations
il est d'arriver à remettre du carbone
dans les sols ensuite vous avez un petit
sujet un autre sujet carbone qui est la
partie émission de fabrication des
engrais azotés donc là-bas - on en
utilise et plus l'impact carbone de
cette partie là est faible dans un dans
un dont les exploitations qui sont en
polyculture-élevage typiquement à ce
moment c'est mais bon général des
habitants le fonds qui a pas besoin de
le contenir
on utilise les déjections des animaux ou
pour amender les pour amender les sols
ce qui est quelque chose qui marche très
bien
sinon il faut essayer d'utiliser le
moins d'engrais azotés possible avec une
fertilisation très optimisé plein
davantage en achètent moins et puis il
ya moins de lessivage
voilà tout et il ya également un impact
carbone parce qu'à la fois les
émanations des engrais quand ils sont
appliqués et les émissions de
fabrication des engrais c'est de très
loin le premier poste de démission des
cultures végétales
voilà quelques voilà quelques éléments
alors après sinon il ya un dernier point
important c'est que dans l'impact
carbone indirecte d'une exploitation il
ya bien évidemment tout ce qui se passe
à laval aujourd'hui on a fait en dans
les pays occidentaux
une agriculture qui est extrêmement
dépendante à laval du pétrole elle en
est très dépendante à laval parce que
l'essentiel des cultures sont destinés à
être transformés chez les fabricants
d'aliments pour animaux ou chez des
fabricants d'aliments pour sommes toutes
les céréales personne ne va dans un
blessé bien qu'elle pas tellement je les
mélange de blessés personne ne va dans
un bled en lâchant par moments je t'ai
blé et faire sa farine donc les champs
de céréales ou les champs de
protéagineux ou d'oléagineux etc servent
essentiellement à être expédiés dans des
usines dans lesquels on va faire des
aliments pour animaux pour coût des
aliments pour homme un peu moins
l'essentiel du maïs a fait la totalité
du magistère pour les animaux une bonne
partie du soja sert pour les animaux une
bonne partie du blé sert pour les
animaux ou la totalité de l'herbe sert
pour les animaux autant que l'essentiel
des cultures végétales assez fait pour
les animaux donc sa part dans des usines
dans lesquels on transforme
puis derrière on transporte jusqu'à des
élevages où il ya beaucoup de
stabulation arsenal et c'est donc la
dépendance aux de l'agriculture à laval
au pétrole est aujourd'hui très
importante
un camion sur trois en france
transportent quelque chose qui se mange
donc c'est vraiment très important donc
pour baisser le bilan carbone d'une
exploitation
il ya un autre élément de réponse
important qu'ils aient essayé d'avoir le
maximum de cultures diversifiées et le
maximum de produits qui sont directement
consommables par les hommes donc si vous
faites polyculture élevage avec
maraîchage flux
fruits et dans l'élevage vous faites
directement les yaourts du fromage etc
ou des jambons et bien vous serez à la
fois plus résilients et plus bas carbone
parce que vous aurez une zone de
chalandise pour la vente de vos produits
qui pourrait être plus petit que si vous
faites uniquement des produits qui
seront derrière destinés à la
transformation voire à l'export vous
avez une empreinte carbone qui est à ce
moment beaucoup plus basses voilà qu'il
ya à la fois les pratiques culturales
j'en ai parlé un peu tout à l'heure et
puis il ya le type de produits cultivés
et dès lors qu'il permette d'avoir
d'avoir un système bouclé avec des
boucles plus courte et bien c'est
quelque chose qui permet globalement de
faire baisser d'un quart d'heure alors
vos mains
ça on en a parlé ça on en a parlé à s'y
tient ça c'est une question pas
inintéressante
c'est lié à l'action individuelle
croyez vous que dans une société où
règne l'individualisme les gens
accepteront de sacrifier leur confort
matériel pour préserver le bien-être des
générations futures
ainsi tant qu' on ne voit la baisse de
l'empreinte carbone que comme un
sacrifice la réponse est non sans
hésiter une seconde
la réponse est non donc ça renvoie à ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il faut
absolument que la baisse de cette
empreinte est là il y avait des coûts
bénéfices de court terme
le coc bénéfice de court terme il peut
être de tous temps il peut être que on
s'insère dans un collectif où on trouve
que c'est sympa
il peut être que on se met à faire de
l'exercice alors qu'on n'en faisais pas
avant et qu'on trouve que c'est sympa
il peut être qu'on diminue son budget et
on se dit que c'est pas une mauvaise
idée
enfin voilà il faut nécessairement un
coût bénéfice de court terme pour que
les gens acceptent de se mettre à ce
genre d'exercice sinon c'est évident que
le serbe est pas donc ça dit au fond ce
que je suis en train de dire que s'il
n'y a pas un petit quelque chose
d'égoïste qui est satisfaits dans le
fait de baisser son empreinte carbone
on ne s'y met pas voilà c'est c'est pas
nécessairement très gênant de le dire
on a tous notre part d'égoïsme mais
c'est un point qui et c'est un point qui
est que je trouve que je trouve
intéressant alors important pas là il ya
un livre qui a fait couler un peu
d'encre récemment alors qui récemment a
également fait l'objet d'une polémique
mais qui pour moi ne remet pas en cause
ce que je m'apprête à dire qu'ils
s'apprêtent qui s'appelle le bug humain
et dans lequel l'auteur fait remarquer
qu'on a cinq pulsions fondamentales qui
sont
extrêmement forte et qui est qui et qui
très souvent pilote no action
rationnelle qui sont le fait d'arriver à
se nourrir
le fait d'arriver à se reproduire le
fait de monter dans la hiérarchie du
groupe
le g oublier les deux autres le fait
d'accumuler de l'information voilà donc
et il explique vianney ça quelques jolis
et il explique que énormément de
comportements sociaux en fait on comme
sous jacent un des éléments que je viens
d'évoquer
eh bien il faut arriver à faire en sorte
que dans la baisse de l'empreinte
carbone
on est également une partie de ces
éléments qui jouent alors bien
évidemment manger le plus possible dans
la baisse de l'empreinte carbone ça va
être compliqué par contre séduire
ça peut arriver parce que vous pouvez
vous insérer dans une communauté où il
ya des gens vous avez envie de séduire
et à ce moment ça devient un moyen de le
faire monter dans la hiérarchie sociale
ça peut aussi être un moyen de le faire
à partir du moment où il est bien vue de
contribuer à alléger la souffrance
collective et il ya quand même un
certain nombre de périodes dans
l'histoire où il était très très bien
vue de faire ce genre de choses
il ya des résistants qui ont risqué et
perdu la vie pour ce genre de choses
donc cette pulsion l'acquis et être bien
considéré aux yeux des autres et donc
monter dans la hiérarchie sociale
c'est quelque chose qui peut être
important il ya des gens qu'on peut
attirer sur ce terrain là aussi je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure
chiche même pas cap de passer dix heures
documenté sur le sujet
par attrait d'accumulation de la
formation c'est c'est donc la réponse
elle est temps qu'on considère qu'on a
rien à y gagner
la réponse et dont les gens ne le ferons
pas mais il ya un certain nombre
deux cas de figure est un certain nombre
de sujets sur lequel on peut tout à fait
argumente et qu'on a quelque chose à y
gagner et à ce moment l'équation se
présente d'une façon très différente
puisque on en retire avec des fils de
court terme ça c'est pas d'action
individualités ça c'est pas d'actions
individuelles
ça c'est pas d'action individuel 1 et
bien je pense que nous ne sommes plus
très loin de la fin
qu'est-ce que je m'entoure comme
question qui nous a écoutés je crois que
j'ai fait à peu près le tour des
questions qui m'avait été en voix il y
est je vais prendre je vais prendre une
question pas individuelle mais enfin
comme il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
voulaient avoir
[Musique]
voilà qui concerne la chine qui annonce
sa neutralité carbone pour 2060 et le
japon pour 2050 et by dane qui le dit
pour les états unis et est ce que ça va
changer quelque chose
alors la réponse ça ne peut pas faire de
mal
bien évidemment ça ne donne aucune
garantie
parce que les représentants ça sera même
quand une action individuelle
les représentants élus dans les
démocraties sont quand même au fond un
reflet de ce qu'on appelle l'opinion
avec toutes les contradictions qui
traversent cette dernière cette dernière
donc le meilleur moyen donc j'ai quand
même ramener ça à l'action individuelle
le meilleur moyen d'avoir des dirigeants
qui commence à se préoccuper
sérieusement des problèmes c'est que
vous étage en dessous il y ait un nombre
croissant de gens qui dans les actes se
préoccupent sérieusement des problèmes
et quand je dis un nombre croissant de
gens dans les actes bien évidemment je
vise les individus et je vise aussi les
organisations d'individus donc les
entreprises les associations des
morceaux d'administration des
collectivités locales etc
le la déclaration de responsables
politiques même sincère ne résiste pas
jamais à une volonté contraire de
l'opinion en démocratie est alors je
prendrai l'exemple très très ciblée
l'ailier au carbone en l'occurrence et
que je les prendre chez nos voisins
allemands
madame angela merkel
quand elle est arrivée au pouvoir en
allemagne il se trouve que ma merkel et
physicienne au chili ce je ne sais plus
et elle avait l'envi de renverser le
plan schröder qui avait démarré quelques
années avant sur la sortie du nucléaire
en allemagne
donc elle a fait voter une loi sur la
prolongation de la durée de vie des
centrales nucléaires allemandes
là dessus et d'arrivée les faucons china
et madame merkel tout pro nucléaires
qu'elle soit à titre personnel a mis en
oeuvre une stratégie exactement inverse
à celle qu'elle avait mis à qu'elle
avait mise en oeuvre juste avant tout
simplement parce que la pression de
l'opinion lui commandait de faire ça et
pas autre chose
donc voilà un exemple dans lequel vous
avez quelqu'un qui était parfaitement
sincère en arrivant au pouvoir qui avait
très envie d'aller dans une direction
à ce stade je ne dis même pas qu'elle
est bonne ou mauvaise c'est pas mon
propos
et qui sous la pression de l'opinion a
fait l'exact inverse de ce que cette
personne avait considéré comme étant
réellement pertinente pour son pays
voilà donc j'ai envie de ramener des
déclarations qui ont été faites par les
responsables japonais chinois et
américains à l'aune de cet exemple c'est
à dire que on verra bien ce qui va se
passer à l'avenir est en tout cas le
meilleur moyen pour que il aille dans la
bonne direction alors après je lui ai un
tout petit peu précises et la bonne
direction pour qu'ils aillent dans la
bonne direction c'est que à l'étagé en
dessous
les gens qui constitue l opinion qui
donc c'est encore une fois soit les
individus soient les soient les acteurs
économiques souhaite c'est en permanence
pousse dans cette direction là à la fois
par leurs actes et à la fois par leur
demande débarrasser des incohérences et
c'est bien ça le problème c'est qu'à un
moment il faut se débarrasser les
incohérences et que ou bien on s'en rend
pas compte
ce qui arrive dans un certain nombre de
cas de figure on ne se rend pas compte
qu'on demande quelque chose et son
contraire
je ne sais pas si par exemple quand un
certain quand les nations unies disent
il faut à la fois alléger la pauvreté
c'est que les gens gagnent plus et
diminuer la pression sur l'environnement
ils demandent des choses qui sont
malheureusement aujourd'hui antagonistes
parce que si on veut que les gens
consomment plus bas ma foi ça augmente
la pression sur l'environnement précis
prendre comme on veut c'est très
compliqué de marier les deux donc il
peut y avoir de la cohérence je sens
qu'on s'en rende compte
sincère et on est bien il ya aussi de
l'incohérence dont on se rend très bien
compte
simplement on n'a pas trop envie d'en
sortir et là encore une fois le meilleur
moyen pour que les responsables
politiques aillent dans la bonne
direction c'est que l étage en dessous
ça pousse dans le sens dans lequel on
souhaite aller alors maintenant un tout
petit codicille sur la neutralité la
neutralité comme vous le savez c'est
arrivé à un stade où les puits équilibre
les sources et autrement les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de l'humanité
cesse d'être supérieur à la capacité
d'absorption des puits ça veut dire deux
choses
ça veut dire que même à supposer que les
puits puisse être augmenté notamment via
les pratiques agricoles
il faut quand même diviser les émissions
planétaires par 4 à 5
il faut diviser les émissions françaises
par 6 à 7 et ça veut dire en ordre de
grandeur que on baisse les émissions de
allez on va dire un qu'ovide
supplémentaires par an 5 % par an donc
le la neutralité
vous pouvez c'est vraiment un scénario
qui est de type et pour quelques
convives de plus donc ça veut dire que
les élections bc cette vitesse là tous
les ans et vous comprenez bien que c'est
un scénario dans lequel on est en
récession permanente
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près ça que ça
veut dire donc est ce que monsieur byden
et le dirigeant chinois et le dirigeant
japonais ont bien compris que la
neutralité était pas loin d'être un
scénario de récession permanente
je n'en suis pas totalement persuadé et
si j'avais à prendre les paris je suis
même raisonnablement prêt à parier
peut-être pas toutes mes économies mais
enfin une petite partie quand même que
c'est pas du tout ça qu'ils ont en tête
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas alors ça va
peut-être arriver quand même cette
histoire et ça finira même sûrement par
arriver puisque connaissez le savez que
les combustibles fossiles étaient en
quantité qualité en quantité finie de
toute façon cette neutralité finira par
arriver mais elle peut arriver dans très
très lourd est dans un état du monde qui
sera pas sympathique du tout le deuxième
au quoditien qu'il faut mettre à cette
affaire c'est que aujourd'hui dans les
puits vous avez notamment les forêts et
dans un climat qui commence à dériver de
manière importante les forêts vont être
attaquées elles le sont déjà en france
et donc les puits pourrait très bien
voir leur efficacité considérablement
diminué ce qui à ce moment demander un
effort encore plus important de
réduction des émissions
si on veut arriver à cette neutralité à
laquelle je le redis on arrivera de
toute façon un jour ou l'autre
de gré ou de force parce que l'infini
département c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas souvent présent en tête c'est
que quelque part notre effort individuel
et collectif va notamment être
dimensionnée à l'aune de ce que les
puits seront capables de continuer à
absorber ou absorbant en moins ou
absents dormant plus à l'avenir
donc tout ce que je viens d'évoquer
jusqu'à maintenant sur l'ampleur de
l'effort et de moduler en fonction de la
part de la séquestration que les puits
seront capables de prendre en compte et
ça c'est de plus en plus une bouteille à
l'encré
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il ya un
nombre croissant malheureusement de
publications scientifiques qui sortent
qui montre que pas complètement sûr que
les puits se porte extrêmement bien
encore en 30 ans dans 40 ans dans 50 ans
ou dans 70 ans 70
donc c'est comme ça c'est un élément à
garder en tête et ça veut dire aussi que
plus vite on réduit est évidemment moins
court le risque que les puits deviennent
très très affaiblie
ce qui veut dire en d'autres termes que
une partie des forêts mondiales mais
c'est ça que ça veut dire aussi
voilà donc ses dirigeants qu'est ce
qu'il faut en penser
il faut en penser que encore une fois
c'est mieux qu'il dise ça plutôt que l'
inverse
mais ça ne se traduira pas en actes si
derrière on n'est pas là a poussé à la
fois par le discours est par exemple
voilà et bien écoutez il est l'heure de
passer à table pour ceux qui sont à
l'heure française et la tension de se
remplir un tout petit peu l'estomac
merci à tous ceux qui ont assisté à
cette petite causeries au coin du coc
vide
et puis j'espère que ça vous a intéressé
et elle utilise la voie là et je lirai à
tête reposée toutes les protestations
qui ont défilé sur la gauche de mon
écran et que je n'ai pas eu le temps de
regarder en direct
voilà merci beaucoup à tous bon courage
pour la suite qui s'annonce et à une
prochaine fois au revoir